(upbeat music)
- [Moshe] Hey this
is Moshe Kasher.
- [Natasha] And Natasha Leggero.
- [Moshe] And we just got
married six months ago.
- [Natasha] Which we think
pretty much makes us qualified
to give love advice
to strangers.
- [Moshe] So,
that's what we did.
We packed up the
car, hit the road,
spread the love.
[Both] This is The
Honeymoon Tour.
- Someone in the back.
- That's the same person
that's been raising their hand
my whole set, who I've
been purposely ignoring.
- Wait, woah woah woah.
- Well, this probably
won't go well, I'm
warning you right now.
- You are so amazing,
- Oh, oh hold-,
- both of you are amazing.
- Thank you, thank you,
come here, come here, oh
you're not wearing shoes,
so this is definitely a good
old Vegas white girl night.
(audience cheering)
Alright. Do you have a
problem with your love life
that you actually
need help with,
or did you just want to say hi?
- I do have problem
with my love life, yeah.
But I probably should be cool.
- Okay cool. Thank you for
coming up, appreciate it.
- Well I tell you what, I will
tell you, it's just funny.
It's funny.
- Okay honey, let's give
it, what's your name?
- My name is Gretchen
and you're so awesome.
- Thank you, Gretchen.
- Oh, Gretchen.
Okay, I got it.
Change your name,
you'll find love.
Next.
- So Moshe, I'm looking at
this hotel in Amsterdam.
Do you care that it looks
like a Hilton Garden Inn
when you're in the
middle of Amsterdam?
- [Moshe] Yeah, no, I
don't, it's free right?
- Yeah.
- It's not like it's a
piss-in-the-sink hotel,
it's like a nice hotel.
- No it's clean, it's
just, it's not charming.
I'm just saying, you're basing-.
- [Moshe] That's
a nice hotel room.
What do you want it to be,
the bed in a wooden shoe?
- (laughs) Kind of.
I mean you're in Amsterdam,
and then you're like,
"uh, can I have my
Stouffer's Microwave?"
(Moshe laughs)
"grilled cheese, or," you know.
There's a microwave in there.
There's like a slip mat
on the bathtub. There's-
- [Moshe] Wait, what do
you want in the bathtub?
- There's fluorescent lighting.
- [Moshe] You want to
sink your feet into like
a four inch thick layer of
Beluga caviar in the bathtub?
- No, I just want
something that feels
like we're in Amsterdam
and not Akron.
(Moshe laughs)
- Ak-er-On?
- [Natasha] (laughs) I
was trying to make it
the same syllables.
- No I respected what you did.
For me it's like, that's
a perfectly nice hotel
and it's free and we
should just stay there
and save our money and spend
it on going to dope restaurants
and maybe even that thing
that we talked about
maybe doing in Amsterdam.
That you said that if I
behaved myself and cleaned up
that you would be down to.
- What's that?
- The thing that we talked
about, about Amsterdam.
- [Natasha] A prostitute?
- I don't like
calling them that.
- [Natasha] We didn't
talk about that.
- I was, I meant to bring it up.
- (laughs) So you're
saying if we get to stay
in this shitty hotel I
don't want to stay in,
that we can finally get a
prostitute for the relationship?
- We can (laughs)
save our money.
- And then she can
sleep in that bed.
(Moshe laughs)
- What's your name?
- My name is Lacey.
- Hi Lacey, that's cute.
And what's...
- What's your name?
- Dave.
- [Moshe and Natasha]
Lacey and Dave.
- How long have you
guys been dating?
- Three and a half
years, four years.
- Four years, and
are you married?
- No.
- Okay, so ask-
- [Moshe] Okay, how
old are you guys?
- I'm 30.
- I'm 23.
- She's 23 and you've
been together four years.
That's what's up
dog, hell yeah bro.
- [Natasha] Damn!
(cheering)
- You gotta get them when
they're a young lady.
- I mean we've been
together for four years
and I talk about marriage
and he doesn't want
to talk about it.
(audience boos)
- Wait a minute,
dude, you're like,
you robbed the cradle
and then you're like,
I don't think we should
complete building the cradle,
I think, you're the guy who
got her all young and shit.
She's spent her whole
adult life with you.
- It is really not about
me, it's, she's 23.
- You think eventually
she's gonna look over at you
and be like, dude you're
old as fuck. Goodbye!
Gretchen where are
you, let's party!
(laughing)
- [Natasha] She's been waiting.
- How many male comics do
you know who have a baby
who are touring?
400?
How many female
comics do you know
with a baby who are touring?
Ah, cero.
Zero, not one.
Because the male
comics are like,
sitting at home and then
all of a sudden it's like,
wah, wah, wah,
and they're like,
"Hello, I'll take it.
"Peace!"
And then they call in,
they're like, "Hey
babe, how's it going?
"(smoking noise)
"(gargle noise)
"Party! Party!"
- When the woman is pregnant
you have to put the
bag balm on her belly.
- [Natasha] the what?
- Bag balm.
- [Natasha] Bag balm?
- Don't you get that
udder cream and you put it
on her belly so that she
doesn't get stretch marks?
- Or she can do that herself.
- Honestly though,
and real talk,
if you get stretch marks,
during the pregnancy,
boom, I'm out.
Divorce.
- What makes you think
that this is the man
you want to marry?
Like, you have so much,
like when I was 23,
I was living in Australia
with a con artist.
It takes so long to
figure out your life.
What makes you think
this is the man you want
to spend the rest
of your life with?
- We've lived together
for like three years
and everything is going
well so far, so why not?
- What Lacey's saying
that makes sense is
if they were to get married,
it would make her
think, okay this is,
now I can kind of see my future,
this is what's
gonna be happening.
But the fact that he
doesn't want to get married
is making her feel
like, oh I'm insecure,
I don't know what's
gonna happen.
- I just want him
to talk about it.
He doesn't even want
to talk about marriage.
- Well there's no better
place to talk about it
than here at the Beauty Bar in
front of 200 drunk strangers.
- [Natasha] Hell
yeah! Hell yeah!
(Moshe laughs)
- By the way, you're 30.
What do you want from life?
- Just to be a professional kid.
That's...
- Oh.
- He wants to be a
professional kid.
- Lacey... run, run.
- I mean Vegas is
just so everything
that I can't handle.
All it needs is rats.
(Moshe laughs)
Then I would be like, not-
- [Moshe] That'd be
your perfect storm?
- Completely unable to be here.
- Dave, you don't have to
commit to marrying her,
but you have to
commit to going to
couples counseling with
her to talk about marriage.
- Do they have
therapists in Las Vegas?
- (laughs) None, there's
no therapists in Las Vegas.
- Are you into therapy?
Would you do that?
- If there were any good
therapists in Vegas, then yeah.
- Okay, would you be
open to talking about it,
maybe even just a
couple sessions?
- [Moshe] Two sessions.
- I really would do
anything for her.
(audience aws)
- Dave.
- Who cares how old someone is?
It doesn't always matter,
it's not like everything
goes in a certain way,
and that she's 23-
- Aw Dave, I like Dave!
- Yeah!
- Hey you get out of
here with your judgement.
(all chanting 'Dave')
- Really there's no,
there's no rules here.
Try to live beyond rules in
your life for once, you know?
- I think that's true,
Dave you're thinking
about it too much.
- And maybe Gretchen allows
you be an eternal kid
in a way and maybe you
need what she has to offer.
- You've been dating Lacey
since she was literally a kid,
and it's time for you,
the perpetual kid,
to, you know, to talk about it.
You don't have to
commit to doing it,
but you have to commit
to talking about it.
Deal?
- Absolutely.
- Deal! We did it!
- Okay, okay!